empathique ou égoïste sur adapté ou
inadaptés bien que paradoxaux ces
exemples sont des caractéristiques
représentatif du fonctionnement de
l'élève intellectuellement précoces une
attitude souvent déconcertante pour les
professeurs confronté à ses enfants le
30 mars dernier la spécialiste jeanne
siaud facchin donnait une conférence à
destination des personnels de
l'éducation des yvelines ces enfants qui
vont être catalogué d'enfants turbulents
ou d'enfants avec un trouverez la
tension alors qu'en fait ces enfants ils
ont besoin qu'on les regarde avec une
autre grille de lecture en fête dont -
la mission que j'ai accepté c'est de
proposer une grille de lecture pour que
enfin les enseignants puissent ressentir
presque plus dans leur coeur qui sont
ces enfants plutôt que de les penser
avec des idées préconçues
comme ils peuvent la voir dans la tête
favoriser sa prise de position si
l'élève est trop effacé ou lui proposer
un contrat s'il est insolent dès que les
détails et pour agir avec chaque élève
sont donnés par l'association nationale
pour les enfants intellectuellement
précoces répondre à leurs besoins mais
aussi savoir les détecter en créant des
cellules dédiées au sein de certains
établissements
nous nous avons des psychologues
scolaires également qu'ils sont à même
de faire des observations dans les
classes de recueillir des informations
de leurs collègues et de faire en sorte
que le repérage soit fait nous essayons
au niveau départemental à partir d'un
groupe de travail départemental de faire
en sorte que l'ensemble du territoire
yvelinois soit mallet et qu'on ait des
correspondants sur tout le territoire
qui sont à même d'une part d'accompagner
les enseignants mais aussi d'apporter
aux parents une première réponse
une cellule fonctionne déjà à
rambouillet alors qu'une seconde est en
train de se mettre en place à saint
quentin en yvelines pour une couverture
totale de tout le bassin d'éducation
yvelinois d'ici la fin de l'année